假设我今天真开了家小店，我最先想辞掉的工作，大概就是退款。
不是因为退款有多难，恰恰是因为它太简单了。
查订单，看看过没过期限，
再看东西发没发，
符合条件就退，不符合就解释。
每一单都不难，但一早上来三十多封以后，我感觉自己已经不是老板了。
我是一个长着人脸的“确认”按钮。
所以我第一反应当然是：这不正适合交给 AI 吗？
我把订单资料和退款规则全丢给它：“今天这些退款，你帮我处理掉。”
十秒以后，它给了我一份特别完整的《退款处理方案》。
第一步，查订单。第二步，核对规则。第三步，判断能不能退。
第四步，回复客户。
最后还贴心地提醒我：“注意保持礼貌沟通。”
我从头看了一遍，又看了一眼第四步。“回复客户。”嗯。
它非常认真地把我的工作拆成四份，然后完整退货给我了。
“你不是都知道下一步该干什么吗？”
“那订单、退款、邮箱，一起给你。”
这一次，它终于没给我写攻略。
第一封进来，查订单，符合规则，退了，发邮件。
第二封，不符合，它自己解释。
第三封，又处理完了。
我把电脑声音开着。
叮一声，少点一次鼠标。
再叮一声，又少点一次。
到第三声的时候，我已经开始查楼下哪家咖啡下午三点还营业。
然后屏幕上跳出来一条记录。
金额大得让我瞬间坐直。
订单备注还拉了老长一串：客户说没收到，
物流显示签收，客服又写着“已补发”，
下面还有两轮来回沟通。属于我自己看了，都得先喝口水再决定的那种。
系统显示：已退款。
我盯着那三个字。
“……谁让你点确认了？”
刚才还觉得它会自己决定特别省事，现在我只想把它的手从鼠标上拿开。
于是我当场改规则：以后所有退款，都先问我。
听起来非常安全。
第二天早上，我打开电脑，二十多个确认窗口整整齐齐排在那里。
一个个像上课举手。
“这笔能退吗？”“这笔呢？”
“这个呢？”“这个可以吗？”
昨天订单是我自己查。
今天它什么都查完了。
最后只把一样东西还给我——鼠标。
很好。
我成功从客服升级成了 AI 的审批插件。
我把那二十多个窗口关掉，
又重新打开退款规则。
59 块，昨天下单，还没发货——它自己退。
2999 块，备注扯了三页，钱出去还不好追回——停。
规则互相打架——停。
做完很难撤回来——也停。
几天后，又来了一笔麻烦退款。
这次它没碰钱。
它把订单、规则和之前的沟通记录全整理好，
只弹出来一句：“这笔超出自动处理范围，需要你确认。”
我盯着那个窗口看了两秒。
第一次觉得 AI 来烦我，也不是什么坏事。
后来我才知道，所谓 Agent，
关键也不只是会不会聊天、会不会接几个工具。
真正变化的是，我开始把“下一步做什么”这件事交给它。
它可以自己往前走。
但到了某些地方，它得知道停。
所以现在我看一个 Agent，第一眼已经不是它接了多少工具。
我只看一件事——
它知不知道，什么时候该自己往前走。
以及什么时候，该回来敲门。